[موسيقى]
يبدا العرب بالتنقل والترحال بحثا عن
الكلا والاماكن الجميله مع دخول موسم
الواسم في شهر اكتوبر فهم يترزقون الله
وينفسون عن انفسهم هو الذي جعل لكم الارض
ذلولا فامشوا في مناكبها وكلوا من رزقه
واليه النشور ومع بدايه الظواهر الصيفيه
بدايتها يرجعون الى قرارهم والى مساكنهم
حول موارد المياه واماره ذلك وعلامته
اجران حادي وقالوا جراند حادي على الماء
ام نادي فظروف الحياه وطلب المعيشه تجبرهم
على ان يتفرقوا والدنيا الله يكفينا شره
ما جمعت الا تبي تفرق ولا فرقت الا
تبي تجمع
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وجل البلدان العربيه سماؤها وارضها بعيده
عن التنغيصات الكونيه فاراضيها بعيده عن
الاحزمه الزلزاليه ومواطن البراكين وخاليه
من عوائق التواصل الجغرافيه ولهذا نجدهم
يتكلمون بلغه واحده ويدينون بدين واحد
وعاداتهم وتقاليدهم متشابهه الى حد
التطابق وهم الامه الوحيده الذين يتسمون
بهذا كونوا جميعا يا بني اذا اعترى خطب
ولا تتفرقوا احاد كعب الرباح اذا اجتمعنا
تكسرا واذا افترقنا تكسرت
فرادى
[موسيقى]